in the end the president won this race
with remarkable ease a walk in the park
but one that came after a fight
our country is full of doubts and full
of divisions
[Applause]
this was not a euphoric speech there was
no triumphalism he thanked his opponents
and looked forward to the future
emmanuel macron's often been accused of
being aloof and elitist and more
interested in the european union than he
is in his own country but this
is a celebration of frenchness we've had
the national anthem there are endless
flags and it's all in front of the
eiffel tower this is macron saying to
his people that after this overwhelming
victory he wants to be the president for
each and every one of them
[Music]
for the people who came to spectate
relief but not really jubilation i vote
for the first two but not solid because
i want either president neither pretty
damn he reminded everyone
that
the values of democracy and the french
republic were more important
le pen supporters have gathered in hope
of a close finish but as soon as the
exit polls appeared the game was up
five years ago she was demolished in the
presidential runoff
this time it was nearer but still the
gap was wide
she seemed unrepentant
so tonight i'm worried that the next
five years
well i hope that they won't be
the same as before and i hope that
emmanuel
macron will try to repair
these splits in our country
macron
enjoyed the feeling of victory in the
party that followed but he knows that
many people voted for him simply to stop
le pen
rather than because of their faith in
his leadership
and that sense of discontent
reverberated across france as the result
was announced in towns across the
country and here in paris
anti-macron protests led to violent
clashes with police
[Music]
in june france will hold parliamentary
elections and in those
he may be bruised
macron knows that even in victory his
country remains fractured
adam parsons sky news paris